what a big day it was over at the talk
yes it was
shannon osborne is gone but her presence
was all over their first new show
since they suspended production
we haven't been together at the studio
since the week of march 10th
don't try and cry because if anyone
should be crying it should be me
during our break sharon decided to leave
the top
we need to process the events of that
day cheryl underwood opened the show
with an
intimate backstage message two weeks
after a cbs internal investigation
determined sharon's behavior quote
did not align with our values for a
respectful workplace
we'll be right back we have more topics
so don't go away i think we should stop
this
i didn't want to be perceived as the
angry black woman and and
that really scared me and it's difficult
to go back to that day
because i just feel the trauma i feel
fearful you know a little apprehensive
cheryl reunited with fellow co-hosts
elaine welteroth carriana nava and
amanda klutz on stage
underwood maintains she has not spoken
to sharon since the incident
i have not spoken to and do not have
any phone call missed or received but
there were
text messages sent to me and the reason
that i did not
respond to those text messages because
they were coming to me during the
internal investigation trauma therapist
dr anita phillips and diversity expert
dr donald e grant both were on hand to
help guide this difficult hour-long
conversation
about race and healing when you go back
and watch
what happened you will see two black
women
walking the same tightrope that
black women are walking every single day
in the workplace